yo bullet cat podcast
hey man shout out to the homie tootsie
in the building
hey man uh last time i saw you was like
in february before the whole goddamn
pandemic
kicked off um you was obviously in a
different space
because now you you know you're the
young superstar now yeah
i'm i'm right i'm doing good yeah well
uh it's crazy because i i just revisited
that interview and uh
you said the same thing you just said on
my hygiene store the girl the girlfriend
asked caresser
so i'm assuming that the uh amount of
other dudes
females whom you're uh participating in
is has gone up since the last time i saw
you yeah
you know wife i asked chris or no the
white so you're [ __ ] dudes wives now
yeah wife you know baby mom was all that
somebody get it let me ask you a
question
cause when i was a savage i just had a
rule if somebody was
married i wouldn't [ __ ] with them now if
they had a man i'd almost be like
even better yeah cause then they they
ain't tripping it's like this
if you married and i'm [ __ ] your wife
that [ __ ] still don't got nothing to do
with me so i don't care you know what
i'm saying i'm
i'm only 20 i ain't getting married
right now and [ __ ]
i know if i had a wife [ __ ] would be
[ __ ] my wife
what i know if i had a wife [ __ ] to
[ __ ] my wife you think a [ __ ] gonna
look at me and be like
yeah nah she married i ain't gonna [ __ ]
her so you're saying that you would
marry the type of woman who would [ __ ]
other men no
i would marry a woman that's going to be
so bad that other [ __ ] are wanna [ __ ]
her
wanna [ __ ] that you said that they're
gonna be fine nah other [ __ ] will [ __ ]
my wife like i know they
they would they'd be in yeah they would
but you're actually going through it
yeah for sure i'm the one going through
with the [ __ ] though if she [ __ ]
somebody else you know
so let me ask you a question are you
afraid of any sort of karma
blowing back for when you do decide to
get married i feel like i am calm
you are karma it's a big statement bro i
don't even know what that means but i
feel like i am come
okay so i feel like i did my dirt i had
repercussions already have you ever
had a somebody's husband uh like try to
hit you like what the [ __ ] bro nah cause
[ __ ] the the usually the wives that i'll
be [ __ ] like they
they husbands be like locked up and [ __ ]
oh so you
i can't be telling all my business so
you you're [ __ ]
okay so you'll [ __ ] uh a wife whose
husband is locked up what okay let me
ask you a question
do you draw the line in the sand if it's
a wife whose like
husband is in the army overseas or it's
fair game
um i feel like
bro i honestly just feel like if i had a
wife
[ __ ] a [ __ ] my wife so if [ __ ] are
[ __ ] my wife
like why should i not [ __ ] other [ __ ]
wives like
like real [ __ ] you only live once yo man
i
you got a crazy philosophy but you know
hey you're 20 years old bro
so ain't nobody can really tell you a
goddamn thing
i'll be chilling